bonjour et bienvenue pour cette option
sont aujourd'hui consacrés aux fossiles
vivants et qui de mieux pour parler de
fossile vivant qu'un authentique
fossiles vivre nous accueillons donc
aujourd'hui notre tricératops mais chez
tricératops bonjour bienvenue le jour du
marché de nouveau le bitume monsieur
tricératops
on appelle à un fossile vivant mais
alors fossile vivant ça veut dire quoi
est ce que ça veut dire qu'on a
découvert vous ancêtres fossiles avant
de s'en rendre compte que vous étiez
encore vivant mais pas du tout
tout le monde ne me connais je suis le
tricératops et puis de toute façon il
n'ya presque aucun groupe animal dont on
ait découvert les espèces fossiles
avant de découvrir des représentants
actuels à part peut-être le coelacanthe
parlant du coelacanthe justement est ce
que ça veut dire que comme livre n'avait
pas évolué et même de 50 est un
imposteur les 50 actuelle de son mari
mais rien n'est même pas une volée que
du temps des dinosaures
il n'existe aucun fossile de la team est
rien en fait
et les 52 possible que l'on connaît
n'appartiennent eux mêmes pas cette
espèce
il ne semble même pas du tout
regardez-le que celui là il a une queue
en forme de croissant celui-là ça que
j'ai tournés vers le bas celui d'un
milieu est celui-là vernon et vous osé
appeler sam facilité qu'elle laisse cru
non mais regardez un peu cette photo de
famille
ils ne sont même pas tous ceux de la
même taille et il veut nous faire croire
qu'elles n'ont pas évolué tenez même je
peux vous dire que ces enceintes avaient
intimé rien il vivait dans l'eau douce
alors que lui je vous le donne en mille
il vit dans de l'eau salée
nous ne lions de mer c'est-y pas beau ça
et il y avait même une espèce hollande
qui n'avait pas dedans et qui ne pouvait
donc pas chasser un peu comme mon papy
mais lui embraye peu ce nouveau nul de
plantes aux un peu comme un roc et
marraines alors que mon papy lui dis pas
non givry ce poisson là est un charlatan
si lui ne pas évoluer en moi je suis la
reine d'angleterre
vous semblez justement voir une dent
contre lui vous voulez rire c'est tout
le monde des conneries que j'ai contre
lui et contre le tout les autres pseudo
fossiles olivan les regards les collines
les crevettes
non mais vous savez combien il existe
des milliers d'espèces de côtes
c'est là qu'elle où le fossile vivant 1
en plus on le sait que leur adn a évolué
alors il faut pas non plus prendre les
gens pour des imbéciles
tout ça c'est rien que du marketing
c'est fait pour faire vendre des
t-shirts des brises des jeux de société
ça fait la couverture des magazines et
ça fait les grands titres et deux jours
les images pour le vendeur mais ce n'est
que de la poudre aux yeux tout ça soyons
sérieux le sait la conte
il est juste doué pour ce londres c'est
tout il n'a su se créer et entretenir
une image de marque de poséidon en
parlant de marque
j'aurais dû la faire de dépositaire de
la marque alors monsieur tricératops
newsletter s'interroge toujours quelle
est la véritable recette pour faire un
fossile vivant
est-ce que ça va un représentant
fossiles et être toujours vivant à
l'heure actuelle mais non ce serait
beaucoup trop facile toutes les espèces
actuelles ont des représentants possible
pourvu qu'on les cherche dans les
couches géologiques suffisamment
récentes comme le bois dernière
regardez plutôt ce squelette de dôme à
sapiens il à 6900 en même pas 7000 même
pas dix mille même pas un tout petit
million d'années est ce que ça fait de
vous un fossile vivant boulot je ne
crois pas être un authentique possible
vivant c'est toute chose en sait
beaucoup plus noble que ça alors c'est
quoi
quel est le secret même s'il me poser la
question est bien dans une phase et le
vivant et il y avait vent donc qu'il
faut être humble et de deux et bien il
ya en face il est pour le tempo s'il est
bien une fois quand je vais t'aider pour
un tram en face il faut être mort
on saura plus sur les possibles on ne
voit comment la lecture qui critiquent
de l'éruption
ainsi que celle des articles sur les
blocs dont l'adresse est dans la
description